grexit has already been a long journey
the people have had their say in the
referendum and a snap election the
government have come up with their plan
now it's the turn of Parliament to try
and shape the terms of our departure
from the EU the Prime Minister's deal is
gonna go through five days of rigorous
debate here in the chamber this is the
chance for MPs to have their say on
Tereza Mays brexit deal hundreds of them
will want to speak some of them trying
to tweak the deal or place down
amendments different groups of MPs from
across the traditional party divides
will team up in attempts to influence
the wording of the vote perhaps trying
to add a block on a No Deal brexit or
guarantees for a people's vote at the
end of the debate up to six amendments
will be chosen it's then up to MPs to
vote on whether they should be
incorporated into the agreement if one
of these amendments passes there may not
even be a vote on the government's own
motion but many MPs think rebels won't
let it go that far after all of that MPs
will finally get a chance to vote on
Theresa Mayes divorce deal in what's
become known as the meaningful vote it's
the culmination of months of
strategizing and negotiation both here
and in Brussels on either side of the
chamber of Commons are the voting
lobbies this is where MPs come and cast
their votes the one behind me is the no
lobby Theresa May will be hoping that
her MPs will come into this one the I
lobby she's having to work flat-out to
convince her MPs to stick with her
hoping she can win around enough
doubters to her deal but some
conservative MPs won't vote with Theresa
May
they'll be crossing the floor of the
chamber go in through side doors like
these to vote with opposition MPs
in the no lobby whatever happens this
will be a once in a generation vote the
UK's relationship with Brussels has
brought down more than one conservative
Prime Minister will Tereza may be the